dieses video muss jeder partner sehen
und eigentlich auch jede mutter und
jeder tochter universum jeder jeder muss
dieses video sehen okay
[Musik]
dieses video hier die reihe ein
wie die täter die mit einem
politik-professor von den kindern die
crash wurde dafür unter anderem rieseby
wo die muttern vaterrolle vertauscht
wurde und die mutter als multitasking
ist super hier dargestellt wird während
der fahrt zum video doch an einer
einzelnen doppelbett zweifelsfall die
verbraucher die damals war wichtig dass
ich dir meine welt geteilt hatte
aber jetzt mal spaß beiseite wir leben
in einer zeit in der mütter 1
powerfrauen der familie gefeiert werden
und die auch da wo der mann ist der mann
im haus für ihn das geld und deswegen
auch eigentlich nie im haus die frau ist
raucher und mama und clementinen heute
sind anders je weniger männer jetzt
alpha stempel aufgedrückt wird desto
eher werden wir auch als täter
wahrgenommen
aber ich wirklich als gleichberechtigtes
elternteil verdient euch geht aber in
meiner sozialen filter blase werden
heller als liebevolle aber auch
irgendwie unbeholfen unterteilen den
tüten dargestellt
die zwar an gut mit kindern spielen
können aber für die jungs gemacht im
internet werden skater derzeit ermüdend
oft mit ghettos in verbindung gebracht
hätten einfach viel schlechte wort liegt
aber wenn sie dann mal ernst wird dann
muss die mama eingreifen ja nicht nur
den eindruck dass man besser für die
entscheidung gemacht sondern dass mama
auch die wichtiger ist mediation nicht
selten wird eine frau schief angeschaut
wenn sie zb nur einen kleinen teil ihrer
elternzeit nehmen
und leider im august stellen landsmänner
schief angeschaut werden wenn sie ein
großteil der eltern sein nehmen wollte
was willst du denn zuhause unten habe
ich euch ein rennteam artikel kann ihn
der krebs und 30 wissenschaftler aller
welt denken
und im sturm kommt dass vater und mutter
liebe gleich wichtig sind in manchen
fällen sogar beobachtet dass die
vaterrolle eine größere rolle spielt
möglicherweise beiden männer mit mehr
macht und respektiert werden was ich
auch die wahrnehmung der eltern
übertragen kann
das gefühl der ablehnung oder
zurückweisung hat einer der schwersten
einflüsse auf die gesunde entwicklung
eines teams eingeführte abfindung kann
bereits durch einen mangel an
aufmerksamkeit entsteht zum beispiel
wenn die mutter oder ihnen der vater wie
ich zu wenig die verzierung mit
einbringen erleben die ablehnung werden
wie sehen die ihren regionen aktiviert
wie bei physischem schmerz im gegensatz
zu physischem schmerz kann der schmerz
eine abwägung noch jahre später immer
wieder durchleben klang und glauben wie
den studien dann hat insbesondere die
vaterliebe einen großen einfluss auf die
wahrscheinlichkeit ob die kinder später
an den kreationen erkranken oder ob sie
zu drogenkonsum aufstrich anja davon wie
wichtig haare rollen die jungs sehen vor
allem in china werden den grundschulen
ein besonders großer bilder an
männlichen minderheiten besteht
doch auch wenn die wärter statistisch
gesehen mehr zeigen ihren willen
verbringen als in ihren töchtern wenn
sie für die entwicklung ihrer töchter
nicht weniger wichtig unter baby schreit
man umgangssprachlich die pro mitglied
einer frau die die aufmerksamkeit die
damen vater der mitte in einer vielzahl
von affären wiederholt werden würde das
ja verraten dass promiskuität auch
wirklich auf ein geringes
selbstwertgefühl zurück zu führen ist
und dass nur bei frauen
ich gehe man davon aus dass politik auch
aufsparen einzelne stellen unseres
denkens kann die wissenschaft sagt hier
freunde die art und weise wie der vater
die mutter oder auch den töchtern
behandelt prägt sehr stark die
vorstellung der töchter von einer
normalen beziehung zwischen mann und
aus wenn auch wie gewohnt orientieren
sich frauen in ihrer partnerwahl am
eigenen war
außerdem beobachtete man eine erhöhte
anzahl an jugend schwangerschaften bei
frauen die eine schlechte beziehung zu
ihrem vater haben
auf der anderen seite beobachtete man
beim frauen die ihre beziehung zum
partner einen waren liebevoll und
kommunikativ beschrieben dass die im
durchschnitt später heirateten und auch
später kinder bekommen das mag auch
daran liegen dass älter die akademischen
beruflichen karrieren ihrer töchter wie
stark beeinflussen können hingegen hat
zudem wichtiger ich betreut zutage
dreimal wahrscheinlicher dass frauen im
selben beruf feld landen wie ihre väter
ich bin das beste beispiel dafür oder
meinen papa heinrich keine chemie
studieren frauen in führungspositionen
haben immer richtig oft einen gesunden
verhältnis zu ihrem vater
und interessanterweise auch keine brüder
wähnte sich die aufmerksamkeit in paaren
teilnehmen
ich will damit nicht sagen dass väter
unentbehrlich sind auch
gleichgeschlechtliche paare und
alleinerziehende können genauere
besonderen glückliche kinder erziehen
die klassische banken auch dafür gibt's
wissenschaftliche studien ich werde
irgendwann sagen dass sie lieber sind
als die natur und bewusst oder
unterbewusst wahrscheinlich wenn wir
mehr dann immer sagen dass sie gute
eltern sein können die bitter ich habe
genau wen wir mädchen sagen dass sie
nicht gewohnt in machen fällen gegeben
sagen ich werde vor die manche oder
vielleicht über viele gar nicht
einschlagen würden dabei gibt es doch
keinen wenigeren job als die tiere
unserer kinder also die gestaltung
unserer zukünftigen gesellschaft oder
nicht haben
und damit gibt ganz viel liebe nach
drauf und alles später oder mütter vor
allem natürlich an meine eltern beide
der hammer sind ich wünsche euch einen
schönen vatertag und schreibe doch die
therapie bedenkt wie wir uns müssen oder
dafür bleibt sicher